what up space fam golson here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story and
it's a big chapter we've been waiting
for luffy's ten crewmates since the
beginning since he announced that he
wanted 10 crewmates in the first chapter
and in this one in this chapter the
final straw hat comes forward after 25
years we also see momo's adult form we
see what feels like the very satisfying
official end and finale of the wano arc
and more so make sure to stay tuned for
that if you do enjoy seeing these
one-piece reviews i want to keep them
coming chiller parking within and smash
that like button in light of wanos
liberation youtube has decided to
release fireworks every time you smash
the like button so be a smashing pirate
king not a passing orochi make this the
video you joined the nakama if you
haven't by subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece reviews and updates and now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all chapter 1051 is called
the shogun of wano kozuki momonosuke
this is of course what i expected i
don't remember where but i heard
theories of hiri being the next shogun
so this obviously puts that theory to
rest and honestly it just makes more
sense for the story even if momonosuke
may not be the perfect shogun either yet
as we'll get into later by the way props
to germa escaping in the cover story
they look cool not looking back at the
explosion and sanji's sister is
definitely growing on me i definitely
want to see more of her in the story so
we start at the capitol where the
scabbards have just shown up but most of
them are still shattered in a cloud of
dust we were just about to see momo's
adult form which has been kept a secret
all this time just one of those things
oda left for us to look forward to
people are starting to get that that
wasn't kaiju's bad dragon in the sky but
another dragon and that there is no need
to flee again as i mentioned in the last
review when this is animated this will
be such an epic moment with the figures
emerging from the cloud of dust as the
saviors of the country after all this
time people have already seen hiri
komorasaki who they thought was dead and
dendro aka boss kyoshiro these two were
part of wano during the 20-year time
skip but then kinemon one of the time
jumpers emerges to people's shock his
pose is amazing too i must say he really
makes the most of the reveal and they
comment on how they thought he was
burned in odin's castle some people even
think they may have passed to the next
life because this just seems like a
dream that's too good to be true then
oda is being pretty meta here hyping up
the moment by having a character say
real or not i think we're about to see
something monumental we obviously know
this as the readers but it's funny that
the people of wano are getting the same
vibes this is very much a payoff chapter
after the long long war and you bet ode
is going to build it up we see scabbard
after scabbard emerge we see what looks
like panda man to mark how monumental
this occasion is in the back between two
citizens we see kawamatsu inuarashi
hokage rizzo nekomamushi kiku notably no
ashrae doji though nevertheless people
proclaim it's the red scabbards who've
been assumed dead for 20 years
tokisama's prophecy did in fact come
true everyone's watching this broadcast
on their makeshift tvs in the different
regions including ringo hakumai and so
on to see what's happening so it's not
just a capital thing it's a nationwide
thing right here even udon is getting
the broadcast we then jump to some truly
epic game-changing stuff before the momo
face reveal it starts off as a hilarious
encounter between yamato and some straw
hats they're like what do you mean your
kaido son so this war isn't over but
yamato quickly points out she's not the
enemy she starts fangirling over them
saying she's been following their
exploits in the news for ages she knew
their crew was made up of a lot of weird
looking people but it's still a shock
meeting them in person and it's true we
got quite the diverse gang here but
yamato is different herself as they
point out she does have horns after all
not something you see all the time in
one piece it's hilarious how she just
announces the following and prepare
yourself she says anyway i'll be sailing
with you from now on i go by kozuki
yoden but you can call me yamato nice to
meet you end quote so this was the big
question all this time would yamato join
the straw hats we've been talking about
this as a community for a long time and
funny enough we also discussed this
exact topic in the newest episode of our
one piece podcast link in the
description animak was more sure she
joined than not and as i said i'd love
for that to happen but i didn't want to
get my hopes up after all her fruit is
literally the guardian deity of wano
fruit so you may imagine it's staying to
you know guardwano especially
considering momo is not a strong fighter
yet and it's not just me saying he's not
a strong fighter at that point we'll be
raised later on in the chapter as well
we'll get into this more later but for
now we see the crew reacting in their
unique ways to yamato's words nami and
usopp looking taken aback frankie
looking a bit skeptical and possibly
irritated of course brook and sanji are
acting like me brook says i approve and
sanji even says not as much as me robin
has a cool response saying haha how
amusing a bit characteristically cryptic
of her in that we don't know if she
means it's amusing to have her join or
it's amusing that she thinks she's going
to join and then jinbe with a very
professional response remarking we'll
need to get confirmation from the
captain before i'll be convinced and
yamato says fair enough now like jim bei
we can't be 100 sure what's gonna happen
yet but it looks good for us yamato
stands it's also interesting that she
wants the crew to call her yamato
meaning we still might get some odin
jokes here and there but she seems to be
developing more of a personal identity i
don't see luffy not wanting her to join
but again we need to see her take off
with them for my skeptical side to be
100 sure since as mentioned she is the
garden deity of wano and momo arguably
needs some more muscle if he wishes to
protect wano that being said this could
very well be the moment the tenth and
final member of the straw hats joined
the crew in retrospect and it would be
very satisfying after 1050 chapters to
have the 10 crewmates that luffy
mentioned he wanted all the way back in
chapter one i also think yamato would
make a great addition considering her
being unique as an oni princess a
mythical zone user a child of a
conquered yonko thus representing how
sun god luffy can overcome all barriers
her connection to ace her amazing power
that let her spar with kaido and so on
besides odin leader of wano went to
travel with roger and then came back so
why can't yamato travel and then come
back after they reach the one piece it
could work but let me know what you
think in the comments yes or no is she
the final straw hat let me know we then
jump back to luffy's current condition
chopper is doctoring him right now as
four kids would say they even mentioned
his new form and how that may have
affected him but nothing concrete as to
its consequences yet we get a funny
moment where yamato yells at some beast
pirates and jinbe concludes well this
one doesn't seem like an enemy at any
rate we then also learned that tama's
seemingly op powers do have a time limit
they wear off in a month and then the
victim can decide whether they want to
remain tame aka friends with tama or if
they want to leave there's some great
moments with horcella saying she wants
to stay and tama saying sure but not as
a servant rather more as a mother and
this just brings so much joy to hercela
nami and usop then see the broadcast and
how everyone is kneeling at the capitol
this is it it feels like momo's figure
is finally about to emerge from the
cloud he says it's been 20 years since
my father died he says everyone has done
exceptionally well to have survived this
protracted winter he goes on saying
they'll be able to go on living as they
wish after the festival they can drink
they can have free clean water the toxic
factories will be abolished slavery will
cease to exist wano has become another
place liberated by the warrior of
liberation aka joy boy sun god luffy
this speech makes tama think back to her
own flashback you gotta hand it to oda
he's definitely milking this reveal of
momo but it works and it's a great short
flashback of thomas we see that thomas
parents died working in a factory she
visited their graves and told them to
rest easy and she'll be okay we're shown
how she sold hats even though people
didn't have money to spare and hats are
not really an essential product even on
days she didn't sell a single one she
smiled and apologized to comachio it's
heartbreaking stuff but luckily we know
it'll turn out well then back to the
flashback we see our boy tanguyama being
kind and buying one of the hats he gave
tom a hope saying don't give in in a few
more years the kozuki clan's mighty
warriors will make their return and
wanna will be rid of those demonic oni
those words gave tama hope and renewed
her spirit and resolve one piece in
moments like this really shows how
important hope can be in life especially
when going through hard times and luffy
is so dangerous to the world government
precisely because he and his adventures
give hope to those oppressed by the
world government or other evil forces
thomas the orphan said she'll keep going
she'll be okay and she did and now in
the present kind of like hiri did
recently tama lets go she lets go
everything she was holding in the whole
time and cries in nami's arms she
recalls how a determined luffy told her
that by the time they leave this country
it'll be a place where she can eat as
much as she wants every single day and
boy did he deliver on that promise momo
goes on to say that orochi's tyrannical
regime and the menace of kaido are gone
for good i still don't think kaido's
dead but i agree that he'll probably not
be making any more trouble in wano as
we're shown a sleeping smiling luffy
momo remarks how he met powerful and
passionate friends on his voyage
together their ninja pirate mink samurai
alliance raided onigashima so boys at
this point it's definitely looking like
a successful raid i don't think we'll be
hearing any more about the raid failing
after this chapter this one arc really
appears to be over and what happens next
will probably just be leading into the
next arc momo says kaido orochi and the
beast pirates have all been vanquished
and vanquished just means defeated
thoroughly which we can all agree with
it's awesome seeing momo hold up the
sword in silhouette form it's such an
epic moment kid and law are pretty calm
compared to the ecstatic citizens
bawling their eyes out momo reminds us
that we'll never forget the heroes who
paved the way to make this possible and
then oda shows us carrot and toko who
lost pedro and yasu respectively they
are smiling knowing that their sacrifice
wasn't for nothing and helped bring
about this beautiful day we get a great
moment where momo acts like the
eight-year-old he is internally and asks
kinemon what he should say now as he
trembles kinemon smiles and says as they
say fake it till you make it a great
moment that's probably needed to temper
momo's sudden epicness he then screams
out that his name was given to him by
his father and it means second to none
he swears he'll live up to it and
restore the country's barren lands to
the paradise they once were but he adds
he'll need the people to lend him their
strength true leadership skills right
here excellent job momo full props to
him we finally see his full figure and
unlike the memes he doesn't look like
whitebeard but of course like odin he
proclaims wano will be led by me kozuki
momonosuke as the scabbers and hiyori
and the people all begin to cry not momo
though he looks like a stoic boss he
lets his father's spirit know he'll
continue down the path odin started the
quick shot of sanji looks very cool and
i love yamato and nami's reactions as
well people are really celebrating the
true shogun's return no one can say that
this is underwhelming stuff in my
opinion we're told sakura pedals dance
in a future sky where warriors can
finally rest their blades in other words
peace has finally come to wano the
narrator says even though momo lacks
physical strength which i mentioned he
compensates for it with his devotion to
duty and boundless compassion we're told
this man will one day be known far and
wide as one of wano's greatest leaders
we have just borne witness to the birth
of the great shogun kozuki momonosuke
and with that oda really emphasizes and
wants us to get how monumental this is
and it truly feels like we are viewing a
big historic moment and for us the
readers who are following week by week
it feels even more like that we are not
only seeing wano history but one piece
history as well by the way how cute is
hyori's expression and when she hugs
momo that's so priceless right there
finally we're told our young hero stands
tall and that's that no specific
cliffhanger as we usually have just the
fulfilling wrap up of wano it's almost
like oda feels he'll cheapen it by
focusing on anything else besides the
monumental victory they just achieved
amazing stuff in my opinion and now let
me know in the comments are you
satisfied with ascending for wano i
gotta say this chapter for me was the
perfect cherry on the wano cake yes we
got a potentially huge reveal with
yamato but also just such a rewarding
conclusion to this long long arc the
only thing that could possibly make this
better is if you smash that like button
and set off the youtube fireworks and
celebrate along with wano and the nakama
yes always be a smashing pirate king and
not a passing orochi that is always my
message to you make this the video you
officially joined the nakama by
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece chapter reviews and updates
finally feel free to check out my one
piece playlist on the screen which
includes videos in all the yonko
mythical zones admirals and much more
link to that playlist and other relevant
videos will be in the description as
well and until next time see you space
cowboys